nous savons en direct avec pierre conesa
ancien haut fonctionnaire spécialiste
des questions stratégiques
internationales et samia maktouf avocate
d'enfants orphelins mondialiste et de
familles de victimes d'attentats bonsoir
à tous les des merci d'être un
allègement ou ce soir on va poser tout
de suite le décor pour commencer avec
vous ça mais un actif maktouf pardon
dans quelles conditions vivent
aujourd'hui ses enfants dans les camps
sérieux bonsoir madame bonsoir monsieur
connaissent à écouter il est établi
depuis plus de deux ans en tout cas par
les organisations internationales qui se
sont rendus sur les lieux et ont fait
état de la situation catastrophique et
dire inhumaines de ses enfants
alors aujourd'hui faut-il rappeler pour
ce qui est de la france qu'il s'agit
d'enfants français qu'il s'agit
d'enfants qui n'ont pas fait le choix de
partir en séries ils ont juste leur
destinée a permis qu'ils naissent sur le
territoire syrien
alors faut-il
leur faire porter la faute sont ils
responsables du choix qui a été fait par
leurs parents oui c'est un choix qui
nous emmène à dire que c'est des parents
qui ont tourné le dos à la république
qui sont devenus les ennemis de la
république
mais ses enfants plutôt que de les
laisser sur place pour que
l'endoctrinement et les conditions
inhumaines fait d'eux les lionceaux du
califat pomme leur envol celui qui a
revendiqué les attentats du 13 novembre
up fabien klein l'a dit foot il est
laissé pour continuer de les endoctriner
afin qu'il revienne sur notre territoire
non pas pour qu'on puisse les suivre et
savoir de qui il s'agit mais pour
devenir des bombes humaines pour se
venger pour pour que leur violence et la
haine qui a été cultivé dans ces camps
de la mort puisque celle et leurs
parents qui visait à amener ou qui leur
en donner naissance sur place ces
enfants là risquent d'être les ennemis
de la république également
alors moi je pense que bien sûr qu'il
faut les rapatrier au cas par cas ni
accélérer le processus ça fait plus d'un
an qu'on n'a pas rapatrier d'enfants moi
j'ai personnellement eu 5
enfants petits enfants puisque je
représente des grands parents mais pour
autant il est extrêmement important de
rappeler que ceci constituera le test
constituera la la manière pour notre
état de droit de se prononcer puisque la
république française et bien d'autres
républiques ou en tout cas état de droit
en europe
ça permettra de prouver que nous sommes
capables que la france est capable de
rapatrier les enfants ses enfants même
s'il risque de présenter un danger parce
qu'il vaut mieux les avoir trait il vaut
mieux les suivre il vaut mieux les avoir
dans le radar qui reconnaissait il était
prévu le rapatriement globale de ses
enfants en 2019 tout a donc été stoppée
on n'en parle plus vraiment l'arrivée
quelques opérations ponctuelles de
rapatriement d'une trentaine d'enfants
présentés comme des orphelins est ce que
vous diriez que les autorités françaises
tentent d'étouffer un sujet peut-être
devenu tabou est ce que comme samia
maktouf vous êtes aussi favorable à une
par une politique de rapatriement au cas
par cas
je crois que c'était la position du
gouvernement français effectivement
d'après cet engagement génériques si
vous voulez on s'est rendu compte que le
problème n'est pas celui des enfants
c'est le problème c'est celui des femmes
c'est à dire que tant qu'on ne sais pas
qu'est ce que ces femmes ont fait
pendant leur séjour en irak si vous
voulez le principe de la nationalité
française n'oblige pas la france allait
rapatrier
si vous assassiner quelqu'un aux etats
unis c'est pas parce que vous êtes
français qu'on va vous rapatriez vous
avez combien actes donc il est normal
que la justice irakienne ne soit pas
dessaisie du cas des femmes quand elles
ont vu des comportements criminels et
vous savez qu'il ya des femmes qui ont
activement participé à la lutte de dèche
javel police pour les femmes est
certainement donc sur le principe il
faut évidemment si vous abordez la
question par les enfants en tête que
d'accord avec le maître makhlouf
si vous l'aborder par la question des
femmes vous pouvez être que d'accord
avec
français c'est-à-dire cas par cas il
faut donc que dans un premier temps la
justice irakienne de la criminalité
possible de ces femmes
les derniers problèmes qui est à mon
avis juridique de droit français c'est
que vous ne pouvez pas dessaisir une
mère de son enfant
sauf si elle s'est montrée indigne de
ses responsabilités parentales
or on n'en est pas du tout convaincu et
donc vous voyez bien qu'on est même en
droit français
face à une situation qui n'est même pas
facile à résoudre juridiquement mais
c'est le rapatriement des mères qui
interroge donc aujourd'hui est-ce que
moralement et juridiquement est-ce qu'on
peut envisager de rapatrier un enfant
sans sa mère samia maktouf pardonnez moi
et permettez moi s'il vous plaît de
répondre à monsieur kone ça concernant
l'application et la compétence de la
juridiction française
oh ma qualité d'avocat de victimes de
terrorisme d'abord je voudrais rappeler
les règles du droit positif qui permet
de poursuivre un français même s'il a
commis un crime un délit ou un crime
d'ailleurs sur un territoire étranger
aujourd'hui la france là les
juridictions françaises sont
parfaitement capables et en tout cas
compétente pour juger ces personnes
alors monsieur connaît ça fait la
différence entre les mères et les
enfants
je pense que ce n'est pas ainsi en poupe
est de mon point de vue que la question
doit être posée
pareil je fais référence à notre droit
positif français qui traite est
parfaitement bien très la manière de
deux d'étudier 7,7 cette question
puisque c'est ma ces mères se rend
forcément suivi pour acheter association
de malfaiteurs criminels ou délictueux
et nous en avons de plus en plus qui
sont rentrés elles sont aujourd'hui
écroués la france prend en charge ces
enfants la république prend en charge
ces enfants ils sont suivis ils sont
heureux
ils ont réintégré le système scolaire
ils sont suivis par des psychologues et
en tout cas des personnels compétents
pour pouvoir les remettre sur le titre
au palais des radicalités je ne suis pas
certaine nous n'avons pas suffisamment
de recul et des procès auquel j'ai
assisté à ce jour et des comptes-rendus
effectué par les psychiatres
nous n'avons pas suffisamment de recul
pour autant il ne faut pas prendre le
risque d'attendre que ses ses enfants
deviennent adultes et reviennent avec
cette décharge de haine avec cette
idéologie mortifère pour tuer tuer dans
notre pays
tuer des innocents comme ça a été depuis
2012 les attentats - de mohamed merah de
nice du bataclan de charlie hebdo de
l'hyper cacher ne faisant pas des
poignets d'enfants de 2 chère de planant
sur cette question sur cet argument
sécuritaire pierre connaît ça quel est
votre sentiment on évoquera c'est
souvent le risque d'une radicalisation
incontrôlable de ses enfants restés en
syrie
qu'est ce que vous en pensez d'abord je
vous dirais que nos méthodes et nos
pratiques de déradicalisation ne serait
ce que sur des radicaux français n'ont
pas d'âme pas été couronné de succès et
donc faire venir ses enfants en pensant
qu'on va les radicaliser six policiers
j'avoue qu'effectivement on n'a pas
encore trouvé la solution miracle donc
ça c'était un principe d'ordre général
deuxième principe d'ordre général
comment voulez vous expliquer aux
irakiens qui ont subi les excès de dèche
et y compris de ces femmes dans leurs
pratiques criminelles qu'on va les
déposséder du droit de juger pour
ensuite les ramener en france
verdi problème pour la justice française
quels sont les éléments de preuve
on va attendre pour savoir comment
condamner ces femmes le seul fait d'être
parti là bas vous sait très bien qu'à
tout autre explique expliqué qu'elles
ont été forcés à aller en irak mais par
contre on ne sait pas exactement qu'est
ce qu'elles ont fait donc je comprends
que le principe de nationalité
obliginfos
ça s'y intéresser mais certainement pas
déposséder l'irak de son droit de les
juger si on veut que l'état irakien se
reconstitue les qui redeviennent un état
normal si vous voulez on va pas
commencer à le priver de son droit de
juger les assassins qui sont sur son
territoire mais s'il est en capacité
aujourd'hui de de juger qu'est ce qui
vous permet d'en qu'est ce qui vous
permet de vous pose la question et péter
chérif inspecteurs chérif un des
organisateurs des attentats de l'hyper
cacher et quelques uns ce quelqu'un qui
a été jugé par la juridiction irakienne
et par une simple transaction il se
reprend il s'est retrouvé en dehors des
de la prison et l'a même su partir et
rejoindre la libye
le national et plusieurs autres pays et
se retrouver dans notre pays dans moi il
ne s'agit pas de donner de dire comment
expliquer aux irakiens moi ce que je
voudrais c'est expliquer au citoyen
français que les de notre de notre
devoir d'abord en tant que républicain
de faire juger ces personnes là parce
que moi je défends des victimes dans les
enfants dans les maris dans les frères
dans les soeurs ont été tuées par ces
assassins et ils doivent rendre compte à
la justice française et pour ce qu'est
dans la juridiction irakienne
elle n'est pas aujourd'hui suffisamment
compétente pour juger dans le cadre d'un
procès équitable est en tout cas
permettre un emprisonnement de sorte à
empêcher ces assassins a rebattu et je
ne prends que l'exemple de péter chérif
et la liste est longue la liste est très
très longue
donc ces deux îles et de notre sécurité
c'est c'est nous protéger que de les
avoir dans les radars sécurité et je me
félicite d'avoir en france un service de
renseignement a servi de cette sécurité
extrêmement performant encore faut-il le
laisser agir pour vous protéger comme il
l'a toujours fait jusque-là tout dernier
mot avec vous pierre conesa un sentiment
de paris se retrouve
de plus en plus isolé aujourd'hui sur
cette question du rapatriement on vient
de l'évoquer tout à l'heure ces 16
personnes enfants de combattants
djihadistes et merdes qui ont été
rapatriés hier de syrie vers la belgique
l'allemagne l'italie les pays-bas ont
déjà procédé à des rapatriements
identique la finlande le danemark ont
affiché leur volonté d'en faire de même
pourquoi est ce que paris ne bouge plus
vraiment sur ce point là il faut pas en
faire un principe juridique transposable
la france est le pays qui a la plus
grosse communauté musulmane de des pays
de l'union européenne
c'est un pays qui a connu des attentats
terroristes que d'autres pays n'ont pas
connu notamment les pays scandinaves
donc l'ampleur du problème si vous
voulez elle est évidemment sans commune
mesure avec d'autres pays et il ya
beaucoup de paix qui n'ont pas appliqué
le principe du rapatriement général
chacun des pays fait du cas par cas
tous simplement ils ne disent pas c'est
à dire qu'effectivement avant de
reconnaître la nationalité va on estime
en discutant avec les irakiens que est
ce que ces personnes sont dangereuses ou
pas deuxième remarque tirait justice
irakienne n'est pas en mesure de
fonctionner faisons de la coopération
judiciaire
pourquoi faut-il déposséder les mêmes
victimes irakiennes des deux de ces gens
là sont les mêmes que ses victimes que
vous défendez m maktouf pourquoi
voulez-vous les déposséder e du pouvoir
et du droit de voir juger leurs
assassins c'est pareil il faut il qu'ils
soient utiles en irak
c'est des conventions bilatérales signés
entre la france et l'irak qui permet de
régler ce problème ce n'est pas une
question d'ego ce n'est pas une question
de fierté de pays
c'est une question de sécurité et vous
parlez des victimes que je représente et
dont je suis fier de représenter et
d'assister et bien c'est maman ces
mamans veulent que ces assassins puisse
répondre devant un juge français des
actes criminels qu'ils ont
accompli il est nécessaire que dans le
cadre de cette convention de ces
conventions et des ces relations
bilatérales la question juridique puisse
être tranchée ce n'est pas un problème
de principe il faut penser à notre
sécurité et pour les français en tant
que citoyenne française
j'en appelle à à l'application du
principe de respect de ces de ses
victimes qui demandent à ce que c'est
les bourreaux soient soient jugés et
qu'on évite d'être en catastrophe et
depuis 2015
on essaye de le faire donc évitons et
luttant efficacement contre le
terrorisme pour éviter de nouvelles
catastrophes et des vies merci beaucoup
et salua maktouf à vos quêtes dont
forfait l'an de djihadistes et de
familles de victimes d'attentats merci à
vous également pierre conesa ancien haut
fonctionnaire spécialiste des questions
stratégiques internationales merci à
tous les deux et à bientôt sur arte
france